Most video games take themselves pretty seriously.
Sure, sometimes a game like Octodad or Sam
& Max slips through the cracks, but by and
large, most games these days seem to be a
grim litany of post-apocalyptic despair.
Which is why inside jokes are so important,
as they often provide a bit of much-needed
levity.
The only problem with inside jokes?
Learning how to recognize them.
Here's a look at some inside jokes only real
gamers will understand — and your guide
to finally catching the gags you missed the
first time around.
Zombie Genocider
You and your friends have probably competed
to see who call kill the most virtual zombies.
But that probably pales in comparison to the
rivalry between the competing zombie titles
Dead Rising and Left 4 Dead.
See, in Dead Rising, there's an achievement
called "Zombie Genocider" that players can
earn by killing 53,594 zombies — the entire
population of the city the game is based in.
Well, Left 4 Dead decided to literally one
up the by putting in their own achievement
to kill 53,595 zombies.
Naturally, Dead Rising 2 responded with a
new achievement requiring 53,596 kills, while
Dead Rising 3 laughed at their own joke by
raising the total to 53,597.
Well, it’s good to have goals, anyway.
Whimsyshire
When Blizzard announced Diablo 3, some fans
were furious because the game's color scheme
looked too bright — which, sadly, is just
the kind of thing that gamers typically get
worked up about.
In response, Blizzard not only didn't change
the color scheme, they responded to the controversy
by adding a neon technicolored zone called
Whimsyshire, filled with rainbows, unicorns,
teddy bears, and happy clouds.
Best of all, getting to Whimsyshire was extremely
complex and difficult, meaning all those super
hardcore fans who complained about the game's
color schemes had to work extra hard to find
it in order to complete the game.
And you thought Vol'jin was Blizzard's best
troll.
Dan Hibiki
When video game developer SNK released Art
of Fighting back in 1992, players couldn't
help but notice that the main character Ryo
seemed to be a direct ripoff of the popular
Street Fighter character Ryu.
Capcom, maker of Street Fighter, noticed too.
They decided to get their revenge by adding
a secret character to their games called Dan
Hibiki, who was a parody of Ryo — and who
totally sucks in every possible way.
"You look like you might put up a good fight!"
"Yeah, right… take your shot."
"Gahhh!
Gadouken!"
Ironically, while Art of Fighting and Ryo
have become almost completely forgotten by
the fighting game world, Dan Hibiki has survived
— and has even become a cult favorite among
hardcore gamers.
Beating your opponent with the perpetually
overmatched Dan is considered a badge of honor.
Daddy's back!
Every now and then, Grand Theft Auto V's main
character, Michael, will randomly shout an...
unusual catchphrase.
"Daddy's back, bitches!"
It's in character for Michael to say something
like that — but it's also designed to drive
a specific group of players crazy.
That's because it's the first line from the
first mission in Grand Theft Auto IV, a game
that's lived on for years in the modding community.
But most mods don't allow you to save the
game, so every time you play, you have to
start over from the beginning and hear this
line again and again.
And again.
"Again and again!
Again and again and again!"
Making one of the lead characters of Grand
Theft Auto V randomly say it is just rubbing
salt in the wound.
The Dopefish
The classic computer game Commander Keen describes
the Dopefish like this: "the second-dumbest
creature in the universe, this creature's
thought patterns go 'swim swim hungry, swim
swim hungry.'"
Aside from his bulging eyes, buck-toothed
grin, and ability to fart on command —
— there's nothing particularly special about
the Dopefish.
Despite this, though, he's become a game designer
meme, appearing in Wacky Wheels, Quakes one,
two and three, Descent 3, Max Payne, Hitman
2, and many, many more.
Just when you thought it was safe to go back
in the water…
Gilgamesh
From chocobos to Sid, the Final Fantasy series
has many recurring creatures and characters.
But there's only one who has an in-story reason
for popping up again and again.
While most Final Fantasy games don't connect
to each other directly, in Final Fantasy 5,
Gilgamesh is trapped in a void outside of
space and time, leaving him free to show up
as a fourth wall breaking Easter egg in almost
every Final Fantasy game that's followed.
Saints Row 4's voice options
One of the best things about the Saints Row
games is the series' detailed and flexible
character creation tool, which allows you
to make some truly bizarre protagonists.
And that level of customization extends to
the voice options, to.
You can give your Saints Row 4 protagonist
one of seven voices, including one called
simply "Nolan North."
"My fellow Americans, I know a lot of people
have concerns about the 'Sunday, Sunday, Sunday
Act!'
But I urge everyone to remember how f---ing
awesome monster trucks are."
Nolan North, of course, has provided the voices
for seemingly every character in video games,
ranging from Uncharted and Assassin's Creed,
all the way to The Last of Us and Destiny,
to name just a few.
Including him as his own, specific option
is pretty funny — and a great nod to one
of the most popular — and totally overexposed
— voices in gaming.
The Cucco Revenge Squad
It started as a joke in The Legend of Zelda:
A Link to the Past.
But the Cucco Revenge Squad, which is a group
of angry chickens that descend from the skies
to kill you if you harass one of their feathered
brethren, has spread like a poultry plague
across the gaming landscape.
Beyond appearing in several Zelda games, the
Revenge Squad has also popped up in everything
from Super Smash Bros. to Guild Wars 2, and
even got a shout out in Hearthstone.
In short?
If you see a chicken in a video game, it's
probably best to leave it alone.
Y'know, just in case.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!